2019 sera placée sous le signe du sport
dans les evil l'année débutera par un
combat de boxe le 16 février prochain et
en courtois marvin petit va tenter de
remporter un titre européen dans la
catégorie des poids légers face aux
belges francesco patera combat qui
l'attend depuis depuis pas déjà regardé
depuis tout jeune crois que j'aurais
jamais gens que j'aurais jamais cru
entendre roy dans ce combat oui là qui
me disent favori et puis les mecs qui me
disent que ça va être un combat dur
après moi je sais que ça va être un
combat qui va être physique physique
puis physiquement je serai là j'ai
toujours une physique ginfray rien et je
pense que je vais lui faire très mal
2019 par craint également le retour du
jumping de versailles après avoir annulé
l'édition 2018 faute de date disponible
les organisateurs ont programmé ce
concours hippique de sauts d'obstacles
international du 26 au 28 avril en face
du château
autre retour après 20 ans d'absence les
championnats de france féminin par
équipes nationales pas de gymnastique
reviennent en ile de france
la compétition sera organisée au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
on attend mille quatre cents gymnastes
sur les trois jours qui seront qui font
la compétition et on espère atteindre
5000 personnes
sur ces événements en spectateur à
quelques mètres du vélodrome nationale
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines accueillera le samedi 16 mars
l'eco trail de paris des milliers de
coureurs vont s'élancer depuis tra pour
parcourir 80 km jusqu'à la tour eiffel
on part sur la base de loisirs de saint
quentin et puis on part dans un une
espèce de chant qui est relativement
beau ce n'est pas évident pour les
filles donc faut faire fort à ses
attentes il faut trouver le bon rythme
parce ce cra metroid en golf l'open de
france sera une nouvelle fois organisé
sur le golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
cette année le rendez vous ne sera pas
programmé fin juin mais du 17 au 20
octobre et devient l'avant dernier
tournoi de la saison en europe
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de dates avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec le rôle mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant remplacé en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire
il y aura enfin du cyclisme de haut
niveau sur le territoire pour la dixième
année consécutive le paris-nice et
lancera des yvelines le 10 mars
le parcours sera officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 9 janvier toujours sur la
route aux rambouillet sera ville départ
sur la 26e et dernière étape du tour de
france le dimanche 26 juillet plus de
40000 spectateurs sont attendus pour
l'événement enfin le stadium de bmx de
saint quentin en yvelines on recevra
deux manches du circuit de coupe du
monde et de coupe de france les 8 et 10
juin prochains
le calendrier 2010 9 et fixer les
yvelinois le demandent maintenant à qu'à
vibrer